Hello.
My name is Ruslan Medzhitov.
I'm a professor at Yale University School of Medicine and an Investigator of the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
And I will discuss, today, our work on characterizing toll-like receptors and their role in control
of adaptive immunity.
My story started in this building.
This is a Library for Natural Sciences of the Russian Academy of Sciences in Moscow
when I was a graduate student there from 1990 to '93.
At that time, the Soviet Union just collapsed and there was a profound economic crisis,
so there were no reagents to... to be able to do experimental work, and there were
not even periodicals available to read.
And this was the only library that still had a subscription to Nature, Science, Cell,
and other journals.
And so I would go there every morning and spend all day in this library on the second floor, and...
just trying to read the literature, since I wasn't really able to do much in the lab
at the time.
And during one of these trips to the library, I completely randomly ran into a paper written
by the late Charles Janeway that changed the direction of my career and life.
And this was a paper in... that appeared in the Proceedings of the Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory
from 1989.
And this is the paper.
It was entitled "Approaching the Asymptote? Evolution and Revolution in Immunology".
And this is Charlie Janeway, who unfortunately passed away in 2003.
But what he described in that paper was a new perspective, a new theory to think about
the immune system that, when I read it, I thought that this is... makes so much sense
and this is going to completely revolutionize our understanding of immunity.
And I got completely enchanted with this idea and this logical framework that Charlie proposed there.
And that was the time when I became interested in immunology.
And to put this into historical context, what the idea was about is how the immune system
knows when to be activated and when to respond to a challenge.
And what was thought at the time is that the immune system -- T cells and B cells --
only react to foreign antigens but not to self-antigens, for example,
antigens that come from our own tissues.
And so on the top panel, you'll see here a situation where self-antigens that may be
presented by antigen-presenting cells -- so, APCs -- to T cells, but there would be
no response.
Even though T cells can see the antigen, they should not be responding.
And at the lower part, you see the situation where there is an infection.
And when APCs detect pathogens, then there should be response.
As we all know, we respond to pathogens.
But it wasn't clear what makes the difference.
And again, one idea was that the immune system distinguished between self-antigens and non-self-antigens.
So, pathogens would be non-self, the immune system will react; self-antigens are self,
and the immune system would not react.
But it... there was also known at the time that for T cells to become activated
they require two signals.
And one signal is the antigen itself, which is presented by MHC molecules,
major histocompatibility complex molecules.
So, it's a complex between MHC and antigen that is seen by T cells.
And what became known at the time, from the work Ron Schwarz and Mark Jenkins at the NIH,
is that when T cells see only signal 1, there is no response that is generated,
but when they see two signals -- the second signal also coming from antigen-presenting cells --
then there would be a response.
And the identity of that second signal was subsequently characterized, and it's
known as molecules called B7-1/B7-2, or CD80/CD86.
So, that was the state of knowledge, and it was... many different views about what controls
activation of the adaptive immune response, of T cells and B cells.
And there were different sorts of schools of thought and... and it was still very much
unclear, for somebody who's coming from the outside of the field, what was going on and
how the system worked.
And that's what was changed with this article by Charlie Janeway, where he proposed that,
in fact, what might be happening is that in addition to T cell receptors and immunoglobulin receptors
there is a whole different set of receptors, that are shown here in blue,
that Charlie hypothesized would be involved in direct detection of pathogens, and that
these receptors would then control expression of the signal 2.
And in this manner, when antigen-presenting cells encounter self-antigens or any other
antigens that are not infectious, there would be just signal 1 and there will be no response.
But when they encounter pathogens, then there would be this detection, by these hypothetical receptors,
of common microbial structures and that would lead to the induction of signal 2,
and that would result in the immune response.
And that was a very profound insight and it was a very beautiful idea that made so much sense.
And... and Charlie further proposed that these receptors, that he called pattern-recognition receptors,
because they detect conserved patterns found in pathogens... things like lipopolysaccharides,
peptidoglycans, and so forth... he proposed that these receptors are evolutionary ancient
and they are involved in immunity in invertebrates as well as in vertebrates, where they control
the innate arm of the immune system.
But in addition, in vertebrates they acquire a second function where they control activation
of the adaptive immune system.
And that was a really revolutionary proposition.
And the only problem was that the receptors that Charlie hypothesized should exist were
not known at the time.
And... and so, after reading Charlie's paper, I started communicating with him,
initially through email, and eventually I was fortunate enough to be able to join his lab as a...
as a postdoc in 1994.
And then my focus of my research was on trying to identify such receptors that can
control expression of signal 2 to induce... to control activation of adaptive immunity.
And at that time, there was really little known about how microbes can be recognized directly.
There were a few proteins that were known to bind to microbial cell walls.
One of them was a protein called mannan-binding lectin from the complement system.
Another is CD14 molecule, which is a GPI-anchored protein on macrophages.
And there were a few proteins known in invertebrates that were involved in recognition of LPS.
But other than that, it was really not clear what these receptors are supposed to
look like and how they... how to identify them.
And a couple of things that changed, that played a role in the development of the story,
was that... one was that in 1994, the year when I joined Charlie's lab, David Baltimore
came to Yale to give a talk in our department, and at that time he just... his lab just started
characterizing the first knockouts for NF-kappaB, which is a critical transcription factor
involved in inflammation.
And there he talked about the phenotype of the first NF-kappaB knockouts, which had
both defects in innate and in adaptive immune response.
And I remember, after David's talk, Charlie and I were talking in the hallway,
and we both thought that whatever it is that we're looking for, it's... whatever these receptors are,
they probably work by activating NF-kappaB.
And then we thought, okay, so one criteria we should use is that they... they are likely
to be NF-kappaB activators.
And at that time, the only two receptor families known to activate NF-kappaB where the TNF family
and IL-1 receptor family.
And IL-1 receptor is the one that we got particularly interested in because of this remarkable conservation
in IL-1 receptor signaling portion with a receptor that at the time was already known
to exist in Drosophila.
And in Drosophila that receptor is called Toll.
That receptor was identified and cloned in Kathryn Anderson's lab by Carl Hashimoto.
At the time, they were at Berkeley.
And the signaling pathway was elucidated by several investigators, including Steve Wasserman
and Mike Levine, Kathryn Anderson and others.
And it was known that this pathway operates in fly development.
But what was interesting for us is that it worked through NF-kappaB in flies, and the
related receptor, IL-1 receptor, worked through NF-kappaB in mammals.
And what they shared is the cytoplasmic portion, shown here in blue, whereas their ectodomains,
involved in ligand recognition, were unrelated.
And because of this conservation with flies, and because IL-1 receptor is involved in inflammation,
we thought that perhaps the receptor that we are looking for would be... would have
this C-terminal signaling domain, and the ectodomain perhaps would be something that
can recognize microbes.
And the only structures that were known at the time to recognize microbial components
were C-type lectins.
So I thought that maybe there is another version of this receptor that has cytoplasmic signaling domain
from Toll and IL-1 receptor, and the ectodomain would be from C-type lectin.
And... and that was my strategy to try to identify it.
And... that... what I took advantage of is that, after many, many failed attempts
to do it through various types of approaches... degenerate screening or by hybridization or
through PCR... took advantage of the fact that, at the time, new types of genomic sequences
started to be become available -- these so-called expressed sequence tags -- that were
just short sequences that were generated randomly in multiple tissues.
And using bioinformatics approaches and using conserved consensus sequences for the cytoplasmic domain
for Toll and IL-1 receptor, as well as for C-type lectins, I started searching
these databases and found several clones that corresponded either to C-type lectins or to
this cytoplasmic domain.
And then I pursued both of them.
And the one that corresponded to C-type lectin domain, I found that it was most similar to
Drosophila Toll.
And this was in some... starting in January, February in 1996.
And the... the gel shown on the left here was one of the first clones that I got,
which was... later would turn out to be a human homologue of Toll.
And the gel on the right in this bottom band...
I still remember that band because this was one of those happy moments in the lab
when I got this portion of the receptor, which was particularly difficult to clone.
And then by doing standard library screening through hybridization, we pulled out a full-length
of the cloning... coding Toll receptor followed by 5' RACE technique, which was at the time
popular in gene cloning, and eventually got the receptor.
And... by about May of '96.
And then another event that happened that... in the... in the summer of '96, we had a meeting
in Charlie's summer house in Annisquam, near Boston, where several other investigators
participated that shared Human Frontier Grant, including Alan Ezekowitz, Fotis Kafatos,
Jules Hoffmann, and Charlie.
And... and Jules Hoffmann then presented work of Bruno Lemaitre from his lab about
genetic work on Drosophila Toll pathway, where they found it was involved in immunity.
So, that was... it was further confirmation for our expectation that this receptor
might be involved in immunity.
And so, then I characterized this receptor in terms of its ability to control NF-kappaB signaling,
shown here on the right.
And more importantly for us at the time, for its ability to induce inflammatory cytokines.
And the most important for us, the holy grail for us, whether this receptor can induce
the second signal, or costimulatory molecule, a channel known as B7.
And that was the... the probably... one of those lucky moments in the lab when I saw
that Toll receptor, which I rendered constitutively active because the ligand was not yet known
at the time, and transfected in this monocyte cell line.
And when I saw that it can induce expression of this gene, that was the moment when
we thought, okay, this... this whole hypothesis, now, we can connect from the beginning to
the end.
And I even called Charlie... this was late in the evening, I even called Charlie and
told him that that human Toll can induce B7 expression.
That was... we probably would be the only two people in the world who would be
excited about that, but nevertheless others also appreciated it.
And so we published this paper in '97, where... which is an extremely simple paper showing
just cloning, and showing these couple of functional assays.
And... and then, subsequently, in the same year, Ben Lewin, who was the editor of Cell at the time,
asked Charlie to write a mini-review about innate immunity.
And so in that mini-review we discussed questions about evolution of innate and adaptive immunity,
and put this schematic together to... to show the parallels and differences between
Drosophila Toll and mammalian Toll pathways, where we suggested that recognition of pathogen-associated
molecular patterns -- things like LPS and teichoic acids and so on -- is detected by Tolls,
either directly or through some intermediary, as is the case in Drosophila.
And that leads to induction of NF-kappaB and various innate immune response and genes
genes controlling adaptive immunity.
And subsequent work indeed demonstrated that the Toll that I worked on is part of a bigger family.
There are about a dozen different Toll receptors in mammalian species.
And it's now known as TLR4 -- Toll-like receptor 4 -- and it's a receptor for LPS, and the
receptor part that detects LPS... actually, a protein called MG2 that complexes with Toll.
And subsequent work with... by many investigators elucidated specificities of different
Toll receptors.
And Shizuo Akira from Osaka University, in particular, played a major role in this
set of investigations.
And what we know now is that... if we... our main interest was not so much in microbial
specificity of receptors but in this idea that microbial receptors can control activation
of adaptive immunity.
And this is what is schematically illustrated here.
So, we have a dendritic cell, which is a cell type that normally activates T cells.
And when dendritic cell encounters pathogens, what's shown on the left side, here,
there is an endocytic receptor that will take up pathogen, take it into lysosomes, and then
proteins will be cut into peptides and loaded into MHC molecules and presented to
T cell receptors.
But that information by itself is not sufficient for T cells to know whether they should become
activated or not, because this peptide can come from pathogens or it can come from innocuous
food antigens or it could be even a self-antigen.
So, T cells have no way...
no way of knowing what the origin of the antigen is.
And the reason for that is because T cell receptors are generated at random.
And each T cell has one single specificity, but they are random, so it doesn't know
what it's specific for.
So therefore, there is a need for another signal, so-called signal 2, which will provide
information about the origin of the antigen that T cell is specific for.
And that is provided by this detection of microbial structures by Toll receptors
-- and now we know, several other families of pattern-recognition receptors --
that detect those structures and induce expression of costimulatory molecules.
And now a T cell that has specificity for peptide derived from pathogen will also sec...
have a confirmation signal from a costimulatory molecule -- CD80/CD86, also known as B7-1/B7-2 --
and then the T cell will become activated.
And in addition, Toll receptors and other pattern-recognition receptors will
induce production of cytokines such as IL-12 that will tell T cells what kind of effector response
to generate.
And that is now, of course, a well-accepted view of how immune response is activated.
And... and it's a... it's very satisfying to see this confirmation of the proposal
by Charlie Janeway, which was at the time largely ignored.
And that now it's become... it's a... it's a textbook knowledge in the... of the immune system,
that that's how activation of the adaptive immune system is controlled.
And Toll receptor was one of the first receptors to be demonstrated to... to be involved
in this process.
So, that's the story of this discovery.
And thank you for listening.